the nevada department of health and
human services releasing a report today
detailing exactly who will receive the
first doses
our sasha loftis has been going through
this document all day she joins us live
in the newsroom with what we can expect
sasha
david the 112-page document details
exactly how the first doses of the
covid19 vaccine
will be distributed here in nevada
through the entire month of december
it also breaks down the rough timeline
of when we can all expect to have access
to the shots
they will be distributed through a
three-tier system across the state and
here in southern nevada
the first round of vaccines will come to
about 164
000 people they'll go to front line
workers and hospitals those who live and
work in nursing homes
and other members of our most vulnerable
populations
now once the state gets through the
first phase of vaccines which which is
expected to happen in january
they will move to phase two which
includes any other vulnerable
populations that weren't reached
and begins expanding out to more of the
general population
phase 3 which we should reach by the
spring or summer of next year
will make the vaccine available to
anyone who wants
or needs it now the covid vaccines
provided here locally will come from two
companies pfizer and moderna
each require two shots either three or
four weeks apart to be fully effective
the state's goal is to of course provide
all of those in our tier one category
with both doses first
we will of course continue our coverage
of this report tonight and have a full
look at what
we can all expect that's coming up at 11
o'clock kirsten